random guy Matt Wallace I don't know who
he is he tweeted this out he said should
permanent gender surgeries for little
kids be banned immediately and he did it
in all caps so you know if people really
mean it when they say in all caps and uh
this Elon Musk guy who you might have
heard of he wrote absolutely uh Sarah
this one's been been sort of close to
your heart because you've been going to
these events which people can't believe
they'd be happening in Texas but they're
happening in Texas talking about the the
drag queen stuff which obviously is
connected then to the larger uh trans
movement
um Florida's outlawing it I think some
other states are going to Outlaw it very
soon Montana's outlawing it
um they're not going to transition kids
it again it's just it's so frustrating
because it's something that everyone
knew to be true up until 10 minutes ago
we all know we shouldn't be permanently
altering children's genitals like this
is it's not hard and it shouldn't be
controversial unfortunately the squeaky
wheel gets the grease in this country
and you have this minuscule number of
activists very radical activists Who
come out and and act as if we should be
doing it and the general population is
scared to say No actually that's abuse
and we won't stand for it the thing is
though as we see with Rhonda Santos as
we see with these other states that are
passing these bills this is a winning
issue it's not hard stop mutilating
children stop sexualizing children stop
bringing them to drag queen brunches so
adult grown men can twerk on them it's
not hard but we need everyone to
vocalize what we all know to be true
that is abusive and should not be
allowed Libby on the on the Elon part of
this how important do you think it is
not only that he got Twitter but that he
has suddenly become this cultural voice
that we desperately desperately needed
you know in terms of Twitter files but
also like basic sanity and also calling
NPR state-sponsored media and you know
CBC up and kind of like just like the
broad spectrum of things that he's doing
that putting aside Republican Democrat
the average person is like yeah that is
refreshing and true and it's nice that
someone's saying it yeah Elon Musk had
said a lot of controversial things and
he's been attacked by the left and right
for them which I think means he's pretty
well right over the target I appreciate
that he's been speaking out against
medical gender transition for minors uh
mostly the surgeries start around 13 and
mostly they affect young girls who have
their breasts permanently removed there
have even been doctors who perform these
kinds of surgeries who say things like
you know if they want their breasts back
they can just get breast implants later
as though there's anything similar
between having a bunch of plastic in
your body and having your actual body in
you know there in your body so that's
actually pretty stunning I appreciate
having Elon Musk speak out because he's
a very prominent figure and having
prominent figures speak out encourages
other people and lets them know that
they're not alone when they want to
speak out against things like puberty
blockers as well if you'd like more sane
takes on our insane World check out our
direct message clips playlist and if you
want to watch more full episodes of our
live round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell